victorian era britain was a time of
massive change from sweeping imperialist
expansion abroad to political and social
reform at home to the
rise of mysticism spiritualism and
romanticism
the nation was growing and in many ways
it was thriving for some
cities were becoming bustling prosperous
hubs of industry but
for the less fortunate they also became
cesspools of
disease darkness and misery it was an
era of invention
and advancement and britain's citizens
learned about it through the newspaper
before the modern era of journalism
there was once a time when the newspaper
was simply for reporting the news
however a young editor by the name of
w.t stead
saw the potential for it to be something
more at one point he described his
vision to
a friend as a glorious opportunity of
attacking the devil
and he did there were plenty of devils
out there rearing their
ugly heads during this time of
all-encompassing change
not only did he attack them but people
listened and he proved that one person
really can be the voice that changes
history
and today while this is stead's story
today's world is connected in ways the
average victorian era citizen could
never have believed
news travels fast they say and today
that's certainly true
it was quite a bit less true in the 19th
century so
when newspapers became widely accessible
in the mid-1800s it quickly
shaped the daily operation of entire
cities
typically newspapers were the only way
people would hear about wars in faraway
lands or the
goings-on of their own governments that
made them powerful and
many built massive and ornate buildings
that towered over the worlds that they
reported on
since not everyone could afford to buy
their own paper public social clubs were
formed and
reading rooms were built where hundreds
of members could get together to share
papers
read the news and discuss others headed
to the pubs where landlords kept papers
on hand and sometimes
paid speakers to perform the news to
raucous applause there were more
newspapers in public libraries than
there were books news agents popped up
everywhere and newsboys hawked the
latest edition with the help of signs
proclaiming the day's headlines
suddenly everyone was learning about the
world and they only wanted
more of it william thomas dead was
brought into their rapidly changing
world on july the 5th 1849.
born a minister's son he could read both
latin and english by the time he was
five years old
and it would be his own words that would
not only shape his life but
go on to change the world he lived in
even though it had originally been
assumed that he would follow in his
father's footsteps and become a minister
that's not what happened at all after
finishing his schooling he ended up
working as
a clerk in a merchant's office in
newcastle while he was there he was a
regular contributor to a newspaper
called the northern echo the editor john
coppelston
saw something valuable in him and
mentored him for a surprisingly short
time the paper opened in 1870 stead got
his foot in the door and in 1871 the
owner of the paper offered him
his mentor's job at the time stead had
never even stepped into the paper's
offices
stead hesitated as he was loathed to
take the job of a man who had been such
an inspirational teacher and meant it to
him but when coppelston left voluntarily
he rose to the challenge becoming the
country's youngest newspaper editor
it was a huge task and to stead it was a
chance to make a monumental contribution
to society he wrote
i felt the sacredness of the power
placed in my hands to be used
on behalf of the poor the outcast and
the oppressed
and that's exactly what he did his goal
was to create a newspaper that was just
as entertaining as it was informative
one that would reach the masses and spur
them to action he started out
in the most shocking way possible with a
topic he'd revisit
later prostitution he called it the
ghastliest curse which haunts
civilized society and at the time he was
splashing it across the front page it
was such a taboo subject that talking
about it was
just as illicit as partaking in it
stead's condemnation
of prostitution it wasn't quite
universal though at the same time he
condemned the wealthy echelons of
society for funding brothels
he acknowledged that for many it was the
only way that they could put food on the
table
stead's preaching from the pulpit and
his almost sermon-like article set the
tone for the northern echo and
for the rest of his career he condemned
entire nations for their politics and
their human rights abuses and he waxed
philosophical on why the death penalty
was a necessary evil
that was a viewpoint that was a bit
problematic considering the paper was
funded
by quakers a religious group who
believed there is a bit of god in
everyone
and that all life is valuable it wasn't
long before stead grew too big for the
northern echo and he headed to london to
take up with the palmau gazette
[Music]
stud continued his fire and brimstone
flavor of journalism when he got to
london but it wasn't particularly
popular
some of his contemporaries hated him as
much as he
hated london and no one made a secret of
it
at the same time that stead called
london the grave of all earnestness his
paper was nicknamed
the dunghill gazette by poet algernon
swinburne
novelist matthew arnold was more direct
calling stead's sensationalist style
featherbrained but as much hate as he
got he also got results
in 1883 the clergyman andrew murns wrote
a pamphlet called
the bitter cry of outcast london it
detailed the plight of the countless
souls
living in the slums of the city and it
was dire stuff
he wrote few who read these pages will
have any conception of what these
pestilential human rookeries are
where tens of thousands are crowded
together amidst horrors which call to
mind what we have heard
of the middle passage of the slave ship
to get to them
you have to penetrate courts reeking
with poisonous and
malodorous gases arising from
accumulations of sewage and
refuse scattered in all directions and
often flowing beneath your
feet courts many of them which the sun
never penetrates which are
never visited by a breath of fresh air
and which rarely know the virtues
of a drop of cleansing water now if it
wasn't for stead this pamphlet might
have gone
unnoticed but the journalist picked it
up and he ran with it using the palmar
gazette as a megaphone
for mern's monologue consequently the
paper increased its reputation for
sensationalism and scandalous stories as
its readers were outraged at the lurid
tales about
what missionaries would find in the
slums of london the paper spoke of
dozens of people huddled together in the
dirt and squalor
of children poisoned by the foul stench
of child
corpses and vermin abandoned to rot the
darkness
the outrage of these freshly realized
details didn't just disappear
manza's words and stead's relentless
promotion of the pamphlet resulted in
new housing legislation and the
organization of missions throughout
london whose
only goal was to alleviate some of the
suffering and misery
described in the macabre tales the next
year stead picked up
another cause the navy calling for an
end to party squabbles in the interest
of national security
he appealed to the government to make
sure its fighting fleet was
indeed capable of fighting the result
was the government making a 3.5 million
pound investment in upgrading its fleet
a
staggering amount of money at the time
say whatever you want about him
but readers were listening
[Music]
sted's tour de force came in 1885
published under the sensationalized
headline
the maiden tribute of babylon this is
when he returned to a subject that he
had condemned earlier
prostitution this time he was kicking
the door wide open on one of the darkest
areas of london's seedy underbelly
and that was the selling of virgin
children to men who were wealthy and
debased enough that they found no
greater pleasure in life than
to quote the exclusive luxury of
reveling in the cries
of an immature child stead didn't just
write about it second hand he spent
four weeks in the streets brothels and
hospitals of london meeting with
everyone from doctors and bishops
to those deemed procures these were
people willing to find and broken deals
for
human flesh and services he thoroughly
documented all that he found
describing the london underworld as a
place with all the vices of gamora
daring the vengeance of long-suffering
heaven
the story that unfolded on the pages of
the palm al gazette was horrifying
stead secured a meeting with the contact
it was connected to all sorts of crime
in the city's underbelly when he
inquired about purchasing a virgin girl
for his pleasure
he was told that wouldn't be a problem
when stead began to ask more questions
about any potential consequences
attached to his actions
he was further assured that screams
would not be investigated
and legal action would not be pursued he
quoted his sources saying
who is she to prosecute who would
believe her
instead incredulous asked for
confirmation that these unspeakable
procurements were common and
was not only assured that they were but
was told
and you cannot help it as long as men
have money procures are skillful
and women are weak and inexperienced it
was something the stalwart journalist
could not walk away from
and could not let continue to happen
while he stood idly by
but just the word of a seedy soul
prowling the shadows of london wasn't
going to be enough to instigate the
change that stead wanted to see
he knew he needed proof and he started
by finding and interviewing former
brothel owners
and those whose innocence had been sold
it wasn't long before he met a working
brothel keeper
who promised it would only take him a
few days to find several virgin girls
whose
untouched condition was verified by a
doctor stead backed away from
communication with this man but
it wasn't long before he found one of
those virgin girls grown
and turned procures who was willing to
reach out to old contacts and
find him the sort of girl he was asking
for the price
three to five pounds as stead waded
deeper he found that crude medical
procedures and
violent assaults didn't bring an end to
the nightmare the children were sold
into
many children most of whom were orphans
or had no family to speak of
were generally passed along to brothel
owners to fill up their ranks or
ended up on the streets making a living
any way they could and there were plenty
of options
as ted would write anything can be done
for money
if you only know where to take it stead
was careful to say that he knew
everything he said was true and that it
wasn't just sensationalist nonsense
because he oversaw the negotiation and
purchase
of a thirteen-year-old girl her name was
lily and she had a family who
agreed to sell her as a household
servant a pro-qrs paid her parents five
pounds and she bid them goodbye
she was washed and dressed and stead's
description of her makes it somehow
even more heartbreaking she could read
and write and he wrote of her as
a loving affectionate child who's kindly
feeling for the drunken mother who had
sold her into nameless infamy
was very touching to behold she was full
of delight at
going to her new situation he wrote
stressing that even though her parents
knew what was going to happen to her she
hadn't a clue
her status as a virgin was verified by a
midwife the purchaser was supplied with
some chloroform and instead recorded
everything including the names of the
people involved
he immediately published the story the
public was outraged and instead got all
the reaction he could have hoped for
and then just a little bit more on a
national level the expose sparked the
passing of the criminal law amendment
act of 1885 which laid the groundwork
for other legislation designed to
protect women and girls who were forced
into prostitution
and also raised the age of sexual
consent from 13
to 16 years old for the party played
stead found himself in front of a judge
brought up on charges of abduction and
indecent assault when justice henry
charles lopes handed down the sentence
he explained that stead's experiment had
failed because he hadn't bought a child
for
exploitation at all he had rescued her
before anything bad had actually
happened to her and that meant
he had published what the judge ruled a
distorted account
of the case and called it a disgrace to
journalism
stead was sentenced to six months in
jail and hard labor a sentence backed up
by the fact that he had technically
broken the law by
getting only her mother's permission to
buy her and not her fathers as well
the sentence was considered less about
the law and more about what stead had
done
mostly his jail time was thanks to the
people who truly hated him the wealthy
men in power the ones whose actions had
a tendency to
condemn in a humiliatingly public way
after stead stint in jail he was never
quite the powerhouse of journalism
he had been that's not entirely because
of how his expose on child prostitution
ended though
in the grand scheme of things it was a
huge success but for years he had
preached some unpopular opinions
including advocating for ireland
self-governance as well as
forming closer ties with both the us and
tsarist russia when he took over at the
palm out gazette
he had decreased his popularity by doing
something revolutionary
introducing decidedly american features
into british papers like
large print headlines bylines for his
reporters and celebrity interviews
there were a few other things ted did
that raised some eyebrows including
offering his unwavering support to the
establishment
of esperanto was a global language
vocalizing his opposition to british
military endeavors like the second burr
war and suggesting that the nations of
the world needed to form something he
dubbed the union international which
would have been
a version of the united nations
dedicated strictly to
global peacekeeping and anti-militarism
but it was
actually an element of his personal life
that eventually gave 19th century
britain
its biggest pause instead was also a
devoted spiritualist
who may have been a little too radical
even for victorian britain and that's
really saying something the spiritualism
movement had been
wildly popular since the fox sisters
claimed to have channeled the spirit of
a murdered man in 1848 and established
contact with the other side
the idea that it was possible to contact
loved ones who had passed on was
obviously enticing and it gained some
serious traction within
a select sliver of the population
including stead
stead left the palm oil gazette in 1890
and founded not only the review of
reviews but
a spiritualist quarterly called
borderland the publication was a sort of
news outlet for the supernatural and
included everything from
astrological predictions and news
stories about ghosts and seances
to reports on research conducted on the
occult vested this wasn't a new
fascination either as he reportedly
experienced some otherworldly phenomena
as a young man visiting hermitage castle
in scotland
it wasn't until 1892 that he saw someone
practicing automatic writing the
idea that some men and women could
channel spirits to write through them at
first he didn't subscribe to the idea
but after giving it a try he
claimed to have made contact with an
american journalist named julia ames
ames had died in 1891 not long after
she'd interviewed stead
it didn't end with just making contact
stead went on to write an entire book
called letters from julia
where he had both received messages for
a friend of the late journalist and
talked to her himself they talked about
grief about the discovery of the
afterlife of
spiritual growth of loss and of hope
regardless of how inspirational the
letters were
stead's obsession with spiritualism it
seriously eroded his credibility
in the journalistic world but if there's
anything we know about stead it's that
he wasn't easily swayed by
unfavorable public opinion he went on to
found an organization called julia's
bureau which was a group founded with
the goal of according to him
attempting to bridge the abyss between
the two worlds the idea he said
was that when loved ones passed on they
weren't just floating aimlessly
off or sitting on clouds somewhere
playing harps they were more alive than
they ever had been before and in
desperate need of comforting the
grieving souls who they'd left behind he
appointed what he called competent
sensitives to the bureau and
their goal was a very specific one they
were only to be used by living
applicants who were looking to reach out
to those who
they had loved and lost stead likened
the bureau mediums to policemen who
reunited lost and frightened children
with their frantically searching mothers
and he wasn't doing it alone julia was
on the other side he said
guiding his efforts julia's bureau was
only active for around three years and
in that time they worked with hundreds
of grieving people and
passed on countless messages it costs
dead around 1
500 pounds a year to run and it ended
with his death
but that's not the end of his story
[Music]
toward the end of his life stead was
derided and ridiculed for his unwavering
belief in spiritualism and
in all fairness he certainly wasn't the
only believer sir arthur conan doyle
famously became a spiritualist his
beliefs cemented in the face of the
senseless loss of life that happened
during the first world war but sometimes
it's only in hindsight that certain
things become clear and in stead's case
he pens some eerie tales that will make
even the staunchest skeptic
think twice in 1886 stead published a
bit of cautionary fiction in the palmau
gazette
it was called how the male steamer went
down in the mid-atlantic by a survivor
and it was the story of a steamer ship
carrying 916 passengers when it collided
with another vessel and sack
the story was in response to legislation
that dictated that the number of
lifeboats a ship needed to carry
was based on the size of the vessel not
on the number of passengers
stead described the sinking of the ship
in agonizing detail narrating the
hundreds of people who had been dumped
into the water the
narrator finding himself amid a
blackened wriggling sheet
of drowning creatures the tale ended
with the footnote
this is exactly what might take place
and what will take place
if the liners are sent to sea short of
boats
stead seemed almost obsessed with the
idea and it wasn't the only time he
wrote about tragedy
at sea in the 1892 christmas edition of
the review of reviews he wrote a tale
called
from the old world to the new and told
the story of the white star line a
majestic whose
passengers witnessed a ship colliding
with icebergs sinking
and ultimately returning to rescue the
survivors he described the sinking in
vivid detail
witnessed by one of the passengers on
the nearby liner the waters bubbled
and foamed i could see the heads of a
few swimmers in the eddy one after
another they
sank and i saw them no more stead often
predicted that his own death would come
at the end of a hangman's noose
or by drowning and not only was he right
but in hindsight that bit of fiction
written from the point of view of a man
drowning amongst hundreds and his story
about the white star line a majestic
and a daring rescue at sea after a
collision with an iceberg
that was more prophetic than he possibly
could have known
it was president william howard taft who
requested his present at a carnegie hall
peace congress in 1912 and
to get there he booked passage on the
titanic his first class ticket cost 26
pounds and 11 shillings
he charmed other passengers with his
stories before he was ultimately among
the lives claimed by the disaster
it's unclear how he spent his last hours
there are various witness testimonies
that
claim to have seen him in the hours
after the titanic's fateful collision
some claim to have seen him reading on
the stern of the ship as it rose into
the night sky
others say he spent his last hours
sitting in the first class smoking room
and still others say that he was spotted
leading women and children through the
chaos
and seeing them to the lifeboats
according to at least one testimony
taken from a survivor named philip mock
stead
actually had made it to a raft alongside
colonel john j cabasta
they had been in the water clinging to
the side and mock-related their feet
became frozen
and they were compelled to release their
hold both were drowned
regardless of how he spent his last
moments his spiritualist associates
would
later claim he had reached out from the
great beyond to tell them of the tragedy
and
that was how they first heard the news
his body was never recovered or at least
it was never identified if his earlier
works had been prophetic
he seemed not to have expected his end
to come in the way he'd written
at one point he had also written that he
expected to be back home in london by
may of 1912. so i really hope you found
the video interesting if you did please
do smash that like button below and
don't forget to subscribe
also why not subscribe to my podcast
it's called the brain food
show if you search brain food one word
in apple podcasts or if you get your
podcast so you are going
to find that show and as always
thank you for watching